[Music]
most of us thought take for granted you
know that we understand how the universe
began with the Big Bang or so but as
they understanding constructive theory
is now offering a new wave and thinking
about that and that's in many ways which
was very exciting and offering new
possibilities in terms of thinking about
how the universe began as one you might
be able to explain a bit more about that
and how constructed Theory offers an
alternative to the existing models well
yes I mean this is was a program we have
so I'll explain images to it the idea
that this is something we would like to
do so the standard way of describing the
universe that we've had so far is to try
to guess a law that explains what
trajectory the universe is on and
just like you would do it with a bowl
and you know when you kick it and you
would like to know where it goes
all the points in space-time that it
goes through from the start to the end
you'd like to do the same with the
universe and we have some candidates for
that but there is of course a problem in
setting the initial conditions and also
in explaining why some initial
conditions as opposed to others
constructed here is completely from
approach to explain in physics so
instead of talking about those of motion
trajectories and things like that
the main statements of the theory are
about what translations are possible or
impossible on a particular subset of
systems of the universe and then from
those constraints for example in example
of what those constraints could be the
conservation of energy which we already
know about
but constructor theory adds additional
constraints from those constraints you
construct the dynamical laws that are
compatible with that and the initial
conditions and therefore those
constraints become the explanations for
those are my close and initial
conditions so the logic is of our
inverted
there is an idea that this could be more
fruitful in solving some of these
problems that currently we have with the
initial conditions of the universe well
of course as I said this is a problem
that is something we are trying to work
out and first we have planned to start
to do to a subsystem of the universe to
find predictions about certain other
problems the cosmological problem is is
very interesting on when something that
is what we worked out in the future
so one of the debates that were having
at the festival obviously is about
natural laws and whether lot the laws
that we import or import on nature exist
out there in the world or whether
they're a human construction I wonder
whether you might be able to have offer
an opinion on that in terms of like
these things that we obviously would
take you know gravity exists even though
it may be don't have a really good
grounding and explaining it to just
offer some sort of your thoughts on an
idea of sort of natural laws existing
out there in the universe and the
universe being governed by these quite
you know I don't yes I so I don't think
that's the necessary hypothesis that you
need to have as a physicist as I was
trying to explain earlier
we're doing the physics dog you have to
solve problems that come up in your
understanding fiscal realities the way
you see it around you and in a way it's
very simple the way you do that is just
you come up with explanations that seem
to make sense of those problems and
solve them so for example when you know
you you saw the sky being full of stars
and planets and things like that and at
some point we were wondering why is it
that they seem to move and why is it
that the Sun seemed to move and why is
it that this doesn't fit with the idea
that the earth is at the center of the
universe which was what we thought
initially and that was a problem and we
found a way of explaining the reality
better in the way that
the soul
gravitation etcetera etc so for that
type of activity you don't really need
to think that all that there is oh there
isn't particular you're just trying to
address a problem in your understand
of course it might be more
beautiful your way to think that there
is reality out there and that's actually
my view but this way in a way it's an
assumption that I am making
[Music]
consistent the idea that actually there
are laws out there and I'm trying to
discover them and this is all tentative
we can never know that the law that we
have is the right one
but what we can say is whether
the reason by solving problems so I'm
thinking the fundamental thing is you
have to assume is way in ways the idea
that you want to solve problems and then
you know way of solving them by coming
up with new explanations and then if you
like you can say oh well actually these
informations are trying to reach for
these actual laws that are out there I
like to think it like that I don't think
is necessary for more debates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
Institute of Arts and ideas at IAI TV
you